-How you been? How's the family?
How's everybody doing?
-Everybody's great.
I just had a new niece
a couple months ago.
-Hey!
-So, she's the fifth one.
Very excited.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
I'm proud of Auntie, which
I got to make this confession.
-Ooh!
-Can I tell y'all?
Have y'all had, like --
They have, like,
these popcorn things
at the daycare at school
where, like, the kids
have to sell popcorn?
-Uh-huh.
-Have you heard of that?
Anyway, they had one at --
My nephew, he's like 4.
He just turned 5.
And my sister hits up
and is like,
"Oh, they're selling popcorn
at the school.
The kids are competing
against each other.
And I just --
I really want him to win."
And my sister
doesn't ask for anything.
So I'm like, "Yeah, bet."
So she was like,
"Can you just tell your friends,
'Here's a link to buy
some popcorn'?"
And I was like, "Easy."
And I do it.
And then she's like,
"Can you also, like,
tell your company,
your employees?"
And I was like,
"I don't want to do that,
because then they'll feel
obligated to buy it."
But then I was like,
I have to pick up the slack.
You know, like I have
to make sure that he wins,
so I'm going to buy
a bunch of popcorn
to get him to number one."
-That's correct.
-And, so,
my older brother is, like,
obsessing over the game, too,
and he's, like,
targeting this one kid
who's actually in first place.
And I'll name him --
-This is 4 years old?
-He's --
They're literally 4 years old.
And I'll call him, like,
Zulu or something.
And, so, Zulu --
He's like, "Oh, Zulu.
Zulu is so smug and he thinks
he's going to take this,
like, first-place prize."
And I'm like,
"Uh, guys, they're kids.
Like, let's chill."
But I'm getting
the competitive spirit, too.
So, like, I spend a lot of money
on this popcorn, and --
-You don't need
this much popcorn.
You're doing this for your --
-I don't need --
Yeah, I just want him to win.
She asked for it.
So, he gets to number one.
And then, at the deadline,
it's, like, where --
It's like 4:50.
And I'm like,
"I know one of these parents --
they're gonna, like --
they're going to try to,
like, get their kid up.
So at 4:59 on the dot, I'm going
to just boost it a little bit."
-That's what I'm talking -- Yep.
That's exactly.
Just goose it a little bit.
-You have to do that.
-You got to.
-So, like, I set it all up.
I put a little extra money
on there
and I hit the "purchase" button
right at 4:59.59.
-Yes.
-And then I realized
I gave it to Zulu.
And Zulu was in first place!
So the family group chat
is going crazy.
They're just like,
"How could this happen?
Parents are so greedy.
People take this too seriously."
And I'm dead silent.
-Does anyone in your family
know that it was you?
-So, I was calling
American Express like,
"Please, can we --
can we cancel?
Like, this is fraud."
And, so, it wasn't until the
next day where they were like,
"Oh, you can cancel it"
that, you know, then I --
then I decided --
Then he got, like, second place.
But sorry to Zulu.
He dropped down in the numbers.
-Wait. So Zulu ended up not
getting the champion?
-Well, because I put
him over the edge,
so I wasn't about
to do my nephew like that.
Like, you know, technically,
my nephew won fair and square.
-He did not win fair and square.
This is a terrible lesson.
-You know what's crazy?
-Terrible lesson
to teach your nephew.
-He didn't even care.
Like, my sister was like,
"You got second place,"
and he was like, "Oh, okay."
-Yeah.
-Had no concerns.
-Yeah,
I remember that whole thing.
I had to sell chocolate bars
when I was a kid.
And I remember doing it
for a Girl Scout cookies, too,
because I support
the Girl Scouts all the time.
And I went to this one store
and I saw this girl
was selling Girl Scout cookies.
I go -- I went up to her.
I go, "I'm buying
everything you got.
Give me everything.
I'm buying it."
And she didn't care.
[ Laughter ]
And then the mom
was kind of bummed, too.
And I go --
And then I'm thinking,
"Well, maybe the mom is bummed
because she's like,
'Look, I've been out here for
eight hours with my daughter,
and some strange man comes over,
saves the day?
Yeah, why don't -- You know,
this is ridiculous.
I put the work in.
Let her earn it.'"
-Let her earn it.
-Butt out, Jimmy Fallon.
Butt out and let
my daughter grow up
and figure out business.
-Listen, if someone had come
to me and just bought it --
Because it's so hard
to just be out there
selling boxes.
I would happily.
I wish you were around
when I was a kid.
-Really?
-Because I gave up
selling Girl Scout cookies.
Honestly, it was just --
It was -- I would eat them.
[ Laughter ]
-You just eat what
you're supposed to sell?
-Yes, pretty much.
-Yeah.
-I mean, you can't trust a girl
who likes to eat with cookies.
So...sorry. Shout-out to --
-What's your favorite
Girl Scout cookie?
-I loved Thin Mints
growing up, which is dis--
But --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Y'all still like 'em?
Then I love them, too.
But now I'm a -- What's the one
with the peanut butter?
Tagalongs. I love Tagalongs.
And you freeze them and --
-No, freezing is
the whole new thing now.
Any cookie, the girls -- They
go, "Did you try them frozen?"
-Yeah, Thin Mints
are really good frozen.
-Amazing frozen.
-Yeah.
-What's the one
with the coconut in them?
-Coconut?
-Samoas?
They're the best.
-I don't think they --
Yeah, kids shouldn't --
[ Audience cheers ]
-No, Samoas with coconut?
For kids?
Kids do not like coconut.
Remember you have
the box of chocolates,
and then you'd eat one
that had coconut inside
and it felt like a violation?
-No. Violation was like
an orange cream or something.
[ Laughter ]
It would bum me out.
It would bum me out,
orange cream.
-That's so real. Or cherry.
My grandmother would
buy, like,
chocolate-covered cherries,
and they were gooey,
so it was like just
cherry spit in your mouth.
-I have things that I
want to talk to you about.
One is I know you have
your own record label,
called Raedio.
-Yes. Yes, yes, yes.
-I also want to
congratulate you on
not one, but two Peabody Awards.
You're a --
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Two. You won two Peabody Awards.
-Yes.
-I mean, does that --
How does that feel?
-I mean, it feels amazing.
So, the second one is, like --
We were supposed to have,
like, a ceremony,
and I was super-excited
about it.
But, you know,
the ceremony got canceled
due to the strikes,
which I support.
So, they haven't --
I don't have the awards yet.
So maybe talking about it on TV,
they'll send it.
But I'm super-grateful.
-Yeah, you got to take your
little victory lap. Come on.
-Yeah, so, they gave me
a Trailblazer one.
And it's with Lily Tomlin,
who is, like, such an icon.
-Yeah, she is.
She's the greatest.
-I hope we still get to have --
-But you are a trailblazer.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-I have a photo of you.
Look at this little --
This is baby Issa.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Look at that.
-Thank you for that "aww," guys.
-This is a double
Peabody Award-winning producer,
writer, comedian, actor.
I mean, you do it all.
-I try. Thank you.
-Yeah, you do it all.
-Thank you so much.
-And you also have a
show called "Rap..."
-Bleep!
-Yes. S-blank.
-"Rap S."
-"Rap --" Yeah.
-"Stuff."
-Yeah, "Rap Stuff."
-Yes. Yes.
It's entering its second season.
It's a show on Max about
two aspiring female rappers.
And it really -- It talks
about the music industry.
For those of you
who follow, like --
Female rappers are having
a big moment in rap right now.
They're being --
They're the most innovative.
And this -- You know,
the second season is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we take a lot of
real-life inspiration,
but it's a comedy.
And this season,
the girls kill it.
It's so good,
so watch it November 9th.
-Yeah, November 9th.
I'm happy for you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then here we go into Viarae.
Talk to me about prosecco.
How did you get involved
with prosecco?
-I love prosecco.
Have y'all had prosecco before?
[ Audience cheers ]
So, prosecco, to me,
like, it's --
I was introduced to it
right before we shot the pilot
for my show "Insecure."
I had a director --
Our director,
our pilot director,
Melina Matsoukas --
we had, like, a
getting-to-know-you dinner
before we shot.
And she orders prosecco,
and I'm like, "What is that?"
And she was like, "You'll see."
And I loved it
because I wasn't at the place
where I could, like,
pop champagne
because I just wasn't
able to, like,
afford champagne like that.
But prosecco felt, like,
approachably luxurious.
And since then,
it's just been, like,
my milestone drink
to celebrate friends.
It's, like,
all the best moments I've had,
a prosecco glass
has been in my hand.
And so I was like, "Oh --"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm going to do something.
My own.
-Recommended it to people.
I love good prosecco and vodka.
And I was recommending it
to people
and I put it in the show,
and people were like,
"Oh, I'm drinking this
because of you."
So I was like, "If they're
going to drink it because of me,
I want it to be from me,"
so Viarae was born.
-Good for you. See?
This is a trailblazer.
This is what I'm talking about.
You are --
We have some here tonight.
We're going to do
a little toast.
We actually got some
for The Roots, as well.
-Come on, Roots.
-Roots, you guys got some.
-Cheers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Cheers to you guys.
Cheers to The Roots.
-Cheers.
-Cheers to you, Issa Rae.
-Cheers, Jimmy.
Thank you so much.
-We love you.
Come back whenever you want.
Issa Rae.
Her new prosecco, Viarae,
is available now.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break. Stick around.